okay so I get started I will write the
title is about our bounds for bye-bye
beer cointegration nice try to explain
what this is
don't work with ignacio garcia' Marco so
this work is about a very very simple
model we try to represent polynomials
in one variable terms of powers terms of
powers of degree one polynomials
okay if if it's going to be a really
univariate polynomial and we want to we
want to have Kevin number of terms as
small as possible so he as usual in
lower bounds where we goal is to find an
explicit point on your for which you
need as many terms as possible now we
should take a polynomial of degree D
basically by counting the number of
parameters there must be some
polynomials which require about D D
terms but the challenge is to find an
explicit example and we have a couple of
examples so just one one familiar of
examples this polynomial here which we
call h2 for some reason but Express 1 to
the power D plus 1 minus X to the D plus
1 so it has degree D and it requires
linear number of turns and we have we
have a fairly precise bound so we we
must have at least D minus one of our
two terms but of course there's a catch
you must have these exponents here must
be restricted to be at most D if you can
use the large exponents of course you
can get away with just two terms so big
exponents help and you so you could ask
what if we allow arbitrary exponents
where we have another example so you
take this family now you take
basically any linear combinations of
powers
our D like X plus 1 X plus y I so he's
like a shift this is any any any any
constant so we are the bitter eyes are
nonzero and why I should be distinct and
we very good for his family is that you
cannot save anything so so so you know
this is already presented as a sum of
error powers and there's no way to
rewrite it as a smaller Sam so you must
have always K at least error so this is
an optimal representation if air is not
too big so the exact value is d plus 2
over 4 so anyway this gives again a
lower bound of order of order D ok so I
try to tell you a little bit about the
motivation for this and the previous
work and and also what you push
technique and watch dear cough
interpolation if I have a time so sort
of a previous work on this
this is some joint work with hkr Shannon
sir and Timothy Pickett and we we
actually looked at a slightly more
general model
we looked at terms of powers of low
degree polynomials to each each Qi you
have to be smaller than some the degree
has to be less than T for some tea you
could think maybe of T being equal to
two that's already in an interesting
case and for for this problem we have we
have lower bounds for expected
polynomials order squared D over key so
you see that for T equals one
of course you're back to this model here
in the order is a square root D so of
course this is this new wizard is a
significant improvement over this only
for T equals one for now okay and what's
the what was the proof method here so we
give we give several examples based on
your shifted derivatives
and also never mated based on the ones
can determinant so it's wizard here we
see this model here which is really
maybe a toy model but the exciting thing
about it I think it's better you get a
you get a better bound than when we
fifty derivatives and you may have seen
lots of recent papers on lower bounds
for automatic circuits based on shifted
derivatives lots of interesting wizards
but I think they got stuck a little bit
but by now and it's more as clear I
think that you're not going to separate
say VP from vnp using just this
technique so it's interesting to find
some may be more powerful techniques so
with this method here that we have is
based on polynomial interpolation and
that's better
at least on a one toy model okay yeah
and I should mention that this is it's
very important here that F is a real
polynomial so as an open problem I could
mention there are many open problems but
you could try to extend these two
complex polynomials try to find a linear
lower bound for complex polynomials the
proof that we but we have really use is
the fact that we have really on yours so
how much time left five minutes okay so
what we what we ideally proof what we
try to do which we try to find some some
sufficient condition for what gives you
V gives you linear independence of these
powers alright so for instance if you
take this polymer here h2 if you can
kind of write it as a small Sturm like
here then this is of course a linear
relationship that you have between these
with these powers so if you have a good
question but tells you that you don't
have any linear relationship between
powers of degree one polynomial richmond
maybe you can whether you're in good
shape so so so this was a starting point
where i try to find a good criterion for
in our independence and so i see if you
if you know about the wronskian you you
know that in general if you have a sake
a polynomials with one second is a k by
k determinant and tells you in principle
if your polynomials are linearly
independent but determinant we are how
to analyze in general it's it's hard to
know when you when they are identically
zero so we we managed to find
some more indirect way of deciding when
jeez when he is uh
when his determinants vanish okay so so
let's try to explain this so we were
given estimate that we were given a
polynomial of degree at most D so this
is 1/2 sub D but via inner space of
polynomials of degree at most D so we
want to we want them to be a linearly
independent so we want we look at the
address space spanned by by the risque
polynomials we want to dimension to be K
now one idea is to look at we look look
at the political this V so we we look at
the you're foreigner of this space now
what we want is the dimension of the
orthogonal be equal to D plus one what's
the dimension of our D minor scale and
so this is like looking at it from the
other point of view and the thing is
when you when you if you choose a good
basis for for your dual space then you
can translate this this question into a
question of polynomial interpolation so
basically you have to find out what the
dimension of the space of polynomials
Attis fiying a given
interpolation problem and let me tell
you briefly what's what via curve
interpolation so and to start with
somewhere something but everyone knows
so Lagrange interpolation in the
condition in separation you have to to
to find polynomial that will take
specified values that some some points
this would be an example of Lagrange
interpolation then we have omitting
interpolation this is a bit more Jenny
or you can ask not only about function
values but there is a leaves you can ask
about the first two derivatives so
instead of for instance at minus one you
could ask not only about the value of F
but you could ask also about you could
ask about the value of maybe even the
second order derivative so if you take
this collection of five constraint this
is a omit interpolation problem and via
cough is even more general lack of
interpolation you can you can have holes
if you want in the sequence of
derivatives that you interpolate at any
any point for instance we could remove
this constraint here so you would ask
about the value of f and and its second
order derivative but there would not be
any constraint on the first order
derivative so that's what the arc of
interpolation is about and it turns out
with
we support him here of finding out with
way to dimension of a space spanned by K
polynomials you can rewrite it as a
problem like like here like react of
interpolation problem and that was a
very nice theory that helps you find out
the dimension so why you guess I'm
running out of time now okay is there
any time for questions
is dependency so you cannot concentrate
yes yes yes yes yes but we yes in in
LaGrange our meeting interpolation you
already have a solution and unique
solution if you have as many constraints
as unknowns as as coefficients in the
polynomial but yeah cough interpolation
is much more tricky and yes that's
absolutely the main issue here
that's right